should we embrace billionaires in space
or is it a sign of depravity spending
fortunes to be
gravity this morning super-rich bald
arch villain jeff bezos
successfully launched himself into space
like a big loogie
the capsule reached a max altitude of
350
000 feet but thankfully the return was
covered under his amazon prime
membership this just comes a week after
richard branson flew a successful test
mission with plans to kick off
commercial space flights next year bezos
and branson are part of a billionaire
space race with tesla foundry elon musk
who is also rich
but what inspires these magnificent men
in their flying machines besides a
desire to escape
alimony laws it's nice they're doing
something our government can't do using
private money to explore the
cosmos on time and on budget which means
space travel could someday be available
even for the average
joe although i'm a little skeptical
anyone actually went to space today
did you see blue origin's official video
from the cockpit
oh check the o2 levels joe
zero gravity snacks engage
thrusters forward
did you notice uh chrissy was actually
delivering an amazon package i noticed
that
why don't you do it i'm very pro i i'm
not going to bash
billionaires for trying to make trying
to do something that we need to do what
do you think
i mean first off they went to space
they went on a plane ride and for four
minutes they didn't have to wear a seat
belt
you can take a flight from uh from miami
to new york on frontier
and have the exact same experience and
it's probably actually more dangerous
than what you saw these people are
acting like they're neil armstrong i
mean i'm sorry
i'm just not that jazzed about it yeah i
i kind of understand
i was more upset digging that uh there
wasn't a woman with long hair
because isn't that always the thing yeah
it's like oh look at my hair
it's all over the place they're all so
like
they're also enamored by grav having no
gravity it's like get used to it we're
used to it
yeah uh wait where's this hair thing is
this like some dream that you
show female astronauts it's or their
hair is always
although it might be the only person no
i'm there with you
now there were no people of
color on that trip
i um this is not just the space race
this is the space
race
i have a life lesson to take away from
this greg please do i
look at jeff bezos and thank to every
young woman don't turn your back on the
guy who looks like marty feldman
or peter falk because he could wind up
being the richest dude on the planet and
you will regret it for the rest of your
life
if you don't go out on that date you
just lose king he just gave a hundred
million to van jones just because he
likes the guy
don't i wish i had a billionaire friend
chadwick
anyway that's not really a question
you know any billionaires uh i've met a
couple billionaires they're very nice
people
yes they are what do you make of this uh
fantastic four-minute voyage
yeah i kind of agree i'm not i'm a big
space nerd i love space it
it's i mean it's kind of nice
distraction from the politics if we can
kind of say look what humanity is doing
but
it's not that big of a deal low subtle
orbit i mean if you're up there like
i mean just being an airplane is kind of
amazing i mean am i the only one that's
still enamored by air travel i mean we
should be right
but where are the flying cars we were
promised do you where are the flying
cars yeah like i'm just i'm just not
that jazzed yeah yeah i'm not that good
i don't say where the flying cars where
are the driving planes
where are the drive i want to draw i
want to drive a plane across country
emily
that's like my car no it's yeah it's
like your car it's a car that goes
really fast what are your thoughts okay
i loved this you guys i totally cried
when they landed
i got super emotional i loved every
minute of it and here's the thing
i surprised myself because i was sort of
a hater and in the beginning i was like
team branson and like yeah
bezos is a nerd and amazon's bloated and
all this stuff
but when i saw that i totally i totally
cried
and hearing and seeing wally funk's
story the elderly woman at 82
at age 21 she competed with all the guys
for mercury seven this was you know a
million years ago
uh she beat all of them but because of
her gender she wasn't an astronaut and
she still
was a trailblazer her whole life and
then i just feel like it
she now is accomplishing what she wanted
to do her true dream
it's never too late it's not too late
and seeing her excitement was really
it was really inspirational and i felt
like they did a good homage to history
like they brought up a piece of canvas
from the wright flyer and amelia
earhart's goggles and i feel like they
were they were really honoring history i
know it's not full space
don't try to shame me into having a
heart i'm not going to work
how do you have amelia earhart's goggles
didn't you disappear
well she flew planes before she yeah
she had more than one pair i only have
one pair of goggles and i
i only wear them when i fly i have one
thing to say to you oh god what sucker
this is a very important uh achievement
because we have to start thinking about
eating something besides earthlings
i want interstellar cuisine and i want
it before
i my life ends because i'm tired of
eating people like
things
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else